SECRETARY WILL CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN ALVARADO, GIL ARCHULETA,
ASHBY, ATKINS, BECKER,
BLAKESPEAR, BRADFORD, CABALLERO,
CORTEZ, DALI, DODD, DURAZO, EGM
BLAZER, GONZALEZ GROVE, PORTO
JONES, LAIRD, LIMÓN MAGUIRE,
MANJAR MIN NEWMAN WEN NILO, OCHO
PAD, PORTANTINO ROCK RUBIO
SEYARTO SKINNER, SMALL CUEVAS
STERN, HUMBERG WAHAB. WIENER
WILK. ACCOR MR PRESIDENT
MEMBERS. I JUST NEED FIVE
MINUTES OF YOUR TIME. FIVE
MINUTES OF YOUR TIME. IF WE
COULD GET TO OUR DESK RIGHT NOW,
WE'LL BE OUT OF HERE IN FIVE
MINUTES. WHERE THE MEMBERS IN
OUR GUESTS ON THE RAIL AND THEN
THE GALLERY. PLEASE RISE. WE
WILL BE LED IN PRAYER THIS
AFTERNOON BY SENATOR LIMÓN,
AFTER WHICH PLEASE REMAIN
STANDING FOR THE PLEDGE OF
ALLEGIANCE. THANK YOU. AS WE
BRING OURSELVES INTO GOD'S
PRESENCE. LET US PRAY FOR ALL
WHO STILL LONG TO EXPERIENCE
GOD'S HEART OF MERCY. FOR ALL
WHO SUFFER AND STRUGGLE ALONE.
MAY THEY RECEIVE HEALING AND
SUPPORT. FOR ALL WHO EXPERIENCE
INJUSTICE AND PERSECUTION. MAY
THEY RECEIVE STRENGTH AND
COURAGE. FOR ALL WHO GRIEVE AND
MOURN. MAY THEY RECEIVE COMFORT
AND PEACE. GOD OF MANY NAMES.
ALL OF THE DAYS OF OUR LIVES ARE
IN YOUR HANDS. HELP US TO KNOW
YOUR PRESENCE IN EACH UNFOLDING
EVENT. YOU'RE ACTIVE, ENABLING
GRACE IN EVERY CIRCUMSTANCE. AND
YOUR ENDURING CALL TO FOLLOW YOU
EACH DAY WITH COURAGE AND
GRATITUDE. AMEN. MEMBERS PLEASE
JOIN ME IN THE PLEDGE OF
ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG. I PLEDGE
ALLEGIANCE.
MOVING ON TO PRIVILEGES OF THE
FLOOR. THERE ARE NONE. MESSAGES
FROM THE GOVERNOR WILL BE DEEMED
RED. MESSAGES FROM THE ASSEMBLY
WILL BE DEEMED READ. REPORTS OF
COMMITTEE WILL BE DEEMED READ IN
AMENDMENTS ADOPTED MOTIONS,
RESOLUTIONS AND NOTICES. THERE
ARE NONE. ON CONSIDERATION OF
THE DAILY FILE. WE HAVE ONE ITEM
ON THE SECOND READING FILE ITEM
NUMBER ONE SECRETARY. PLEASE
READ SENATE AND CURRENT
RESOLUTION 119. IF THERE'S NÓ
OTHER BUSINESS IN MAGUIRE, THAT
DOES IS CLEAR. FIRST OF ALL,
JUST WANT TO SAY THANK YOU TO
MADAM PRESIDENT AND WE ARE SO
EXCITED FOR YOU TO BE PRESIDING.
IF WE CAN GIVE A ROUND OF
APPLAUSE, PLEASE. MY GOODNESS.
MADAM PRESIDENT. WE RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST ALL MEMBERS WALK OVER
TOGETHER FOR THE ANNUAL STATE OF
JUDICIARY ADDRESS BY CHIEF
JUSTICE GUERRERO. THE NEXT
SENATE SESSION IS THURSDAY,
MARCH 21ST AT 9 A.M. SENATORS
WILL BE FREE TO LEAVE
IMMEDIATELY FOLLOWING THE STATE
OF JUDICIARY ADDRESS. THANK YOU,
MADAM SENATOR. THE SENATE WOULD
BE IN RECESS UNTIL 4 P.M. AT
WHICH TIME THE ADJOURNMENT
MOTION WILL BE MADE. WE WILL
RECONVENE THURSDAY AT 9 A.M. SEE
YOU IN THE ASSEMBLY FLOOR.